good evening my name is sebastian
i'm an international master from norway
and i'm here to take you through the
game jana pomnyechi against
magnus carlsen from the very first round
of the skilling
skilling open and uh boy
this game was uh an experience to say
the least
so let's uh just jump right into it so
e45 not
f3 knight c6 uh yeah on the opponent she
chose to play
bishop b5 so here we have the spanish
spanish opening so magnus already after
three moves he played a surprising move
knight ge7 and this is certainly strange
because normally you would like to place
your knight into the center with knight
of six
or kick away the bishop with basics and
both of these moves are very very
popular in this position and arguably
better but i'm sure magnus had
something in mind and that he had looked
at this beforehand
so knight g7 ayanna pomenacci continues
with knight c3
developing the other knight magnus moves
his knight to
g6 so he can place his bishop on c5
but napoli stops this with d4 he already
strikes in the center
which is a very good move and i'm
after it takes takes i must say that i
do like yan's position here he has
good control over the center bishop c5
bishop e3
and the yawn is getting ready to castle
along with the queen detouring castle
in the near future so magnus he takes
and dion takes back and
i did take a look and apparently
magnus's move with the queen g5
is uh it's a first timer in this
position
certainly an interesting move attacking
upon on g g2 but this is easy to defend
with the g3
queen takes a knight takes d4 queen
takes d4 we can also look at the bar
here on this
uh on the left side and uh
indeed white has a nice position because
of the
control of the center so knight d5
black is threatening to play out of
three a very nasty fork
but it's easily dodged by yon who played
bishop e2 protecting against knight of
three and he's
also threatening to play f4 attacking
both the queen and g5
and in iron e5 so magnus moves back
jan moves his queen and d6 opening up
for the
for the diagonal knight t5 attacking c7
and the only move really is to play
queen d8
and this is looking scary it's looking
scarier now for for black than it did
earlier uh
john plays queen c3 he's attacking on g7
castles castles and um
well white is getting ready to attack
the king's side here with h4 h5 h6
possibly coming or g4 f4 could come even
and it's not so
simple for for black to start its attack
on
on the queen side here but magnus plays
rook e8
f3 bishop e6 all very natural moves here
from
from magnus he finally has
his his bishop developed here bishop b5
bishop d7 protects the knight and
h4 yawn is going all in and that's
certainly a very good move too
and a6 from uh from magnus and here
jan makes a a slight error
um i think a better move would have been
to play bishop e2
because when he plays bishop a4 he gives
magnus
b5 with the tempo and that's a very
very good for for magnus because now he
actually gets his attack going
and his pawns are now faster than yan's
pawns on the king
side which would have been decisive
uh we'll see why soon of course it was
i'm still mind blown of what happened
later in the game but we'll get to that
soon enough so a3
b4 here is a very good pawn sacrifice
for from magnus he wants to open up the
a file
takes takes knight takes knight takes
queen takes this is looking
dangerous for black now white black no
for white i mean
sorry black finally has an attack so
bishop b6
takes takes and uh we have a very
dynamic position
on our hands here where it could go uh
wrong for either color uh queen c3
just moves the queen out of the way h5
magnus wants to stop uh the palm natchez
pawns
and also he creates a square for his
king if that's needed
b3 kind of a safe move as well
in the near future the king could maybe
go to b2 and the rook could come to a1
rook g6 f4
rook a6 another plan could be to put the
rook on c6
to attack against c2 king b2 there you
go
and the magnus played rook e6
and it's already looking um better for
for yon i must say
e5 probably would have been a very
strong move
but jan also plays the logical queen c4
queen f6 check c3 rook a8
rookie one queen e7 some more pressure
against e4
rook t5 and that is the actually
decisive blunder
rook d5 which is kind of crazy because
it's such a natural move attacking
the pawn on h5 a better move would have
been maybe to play something like
um queen c6
but it's not so simple after rook b8
black has a lot of compensation the
position is very complicated
and i wouldn't be very very happy with
the white here
so um but we go back to
rook d5 and hear magnus plays the
incredible move
c6 attacking the rook and
not only that more importantly it's
opening up for queen a7
and after queen a7 either queen a2 or
queen f2
check could come with a blasting effect
to say the least so if the palm nation
would have taken that pawn with queen
take c6 which is a very
natural move then queen a7 will come
threatening queen a2
or queen f2 for example
king c2 queen f2 king d3
uh bear in mind that white's attacking
black strike so maybe rook e8 but then
no rook e8 i mean i'm sorry the main
point being rook c8 and this is just
way too too dangerous for
for white with also queen takes g3
coming
um so queen takes c6 would have lost so
yani decided to play rook d4
but it doesn't help because magnus c
strikes with d5
queen e2 queen a3 king c king c2 queen
a2 check
king d3 queen takes b3 it's all falling
apart for
free on here it's far far too dangerous
and after queen c2 the absolute
shocker happens this is uh this has
happened to
to everyone i would say who has played
chess online
magnus he makes the slip and plays queen
b4 which of course
hangs the queen i can't imagine
how he felt after making that making
that slip
oh oh man it was absolutely incredible
to watch
i honest i can't i just can't imagine
how you must must have felt after
playing that because of course this
position is
uh is winning it's far far too dangerous
for um
for an appomachi an apomolacci he gets a
gift
he simply gets a gift right into his
hands here and after
a queen b5 check and maybe uh
king d2 looks very large fairly logical
it's too difficult to
to protect every single target here for
example after rook g6
rook e3 and then all of a sudden c5
could come or maybe d take c4 to open up
the
position even more rook a1 could come
queen f1
also in the future this is um
white's not going to survive but instead
jan and pomnechi
gets a gift right into his his hands
here
after queen before and he get he gets
off to a great great start with a
victory over
the world champion